The world is about to plug back into the Matrix,
but will Laurence Fishburne be on the other
side this time around?
Warner Bros. dropped a bombshell on August
20 when it announced that filmmaker Lana Wachowski
- one half of the directorial duo behind the
original Matrix trilogy - is set to write
and direct the long-awaited fourth Matrix
film.
Keanu Reeves will reprise his role as Neo,
and his co-star Carrie-Anne Moss is confirmed
to step back into her role as Nebuchadnezzar
crew member and Neo's love interest Trinity.
That news break came as a welcome surprise,
and it seemed that The Matrix 4 would be one
big Matrix family reunion.
The only problem?
There was no mention of Laurence Fishburne's
involvement in the film.
Fishburne starred opposite Reeves and Moss
in all three Matrix movies, playing Morpheus,
the Nebuchadnezzar captain who recruited Neo
to aid in the fight to break humanity free
from the virtual reality known as the Matrix.
Considering Morpheus, Neo, and Trinity are
the core trio of the Matrix franchise, and
given that Reeves and Moss are locked in for
The Matrix 4, you'd assume that Fishburne
would also come back for the upcoming film.
However, that might not end up happening.
According to Variety's Justin Kroll, Fishburne
may not return because the film might not
include his character at his current age.
The Matrix 4 will reportedly feature a younger
version of Morpheus, and Warner Bros. is said
to be on the hunt for the perfect person for
the gig.
Shortly after the initial news broke, Kroll
wrote on Twitter:
"If you've asked yourself, 'Where's [Morpheus],'
sources have told me this may point to where
and when the film is set as I've heard execs
are looking at a variety of actors to possibly
play 'young [Morpheus].'
Stay tuned on that front…"
Now, just because Warner Bros. is apparently
in an active search for the right person to
portray a fresh-faced version of everyone's
favorite freedom fighter doesn't completely
rule out the possibility that Fishburne will
appear in The Matrix 4.
Someone new to the Matrix franchise might
step up and portray young Morpheus, with Fishburne
still appearing as the regular-aged version
of himself.
Anything can happen in in the Matrix.
Perhaps Warner Bros. knows exactly what it's
doing here, and is purposefully holding out
on announcing Fishburne's inclusion to build
additional buzz around the new Matrix.
The studio already hit us with huge news when
it confirmed that the project was happening.
Maybe Warner Bros. brass doesn't want to give
franchise fans everything all at once, and
is holding onto the juicy tidbit that is Fishburne's
potential involvement until a later date.
"They are guarding all the doors, they are
holding all the keys, which means that sooner
or later someone is going to have to fight
them."
On that note, there's also the chance that
Warner Bros. is still negotiating with Fishburne
about returning as Morpheus.
It isn't every day that an actor learns that
the franchise they last appeared in 16 years
ago is getting another installment, and Fishburne
could very well be conflicted about the idea
of being a part of the new movie.
He has remained incredibly busy in the time
since The Matrix Revolutions debuted in 2003
- appearing in films like Mission: Impossible
III, Days of Wrath, Predators, Man of Steel,
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, Ant-Man
and the Wasp, and two of the John Wick films.
Fishburne has also found success on the small
screen in his post-Matrix life, playing Dr.
Raymond Langston on a handful of CSI series,
Jack Crawford on Hannibal, and Earl "Pops"
Johnson on Black-ish and Grown-ish.
Clearly, the guy has been doing pretty well
for himself over the years.
This considered, it's plausible that Fishburne
is completely satisfied with his professional
life and may not be interested in reprising
his Matrix role that he hung up so many years
ago.
It's a mystery for now whether Fishburne will
be involved in The Matrix 4, but for our part,
we're holding out hope that we'll get to hear
him say a few iconic lines at least one more
time.
"Free your mind."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.